the Jazz are really happy with what they
have in Ruby oh yeah I think so too and
Mike wells and guys and there's
-
they could really shoot we got all the
big buddy that's a party with a step
back off the back of the iron
lion kept it alive and hard
and any other rookie in Utah history
except for one Darrell Griffith the
doctor of dumb
this were drafted and pitch it up banana
[Music]
to prove itself once again three seconds
down to two down to one as hard
[Applause]
[Music]
you play so to close the trigger
and fire James Harden for 8 from the
field
first quarter points which is made
shoots it again James Hunt who knows
other favors got seven rebounds already
and back outside
very nice wishes today
66 points for Houston
[Music]
[Applause]
nay's to the basket for to Anwar
[Applause]
move hard coming out of the
pick-and-roll De Niro's stretch new
acrobatic Center
you don't want to go under that high
picking most
[Music]
over the other night Simmons and Kuzma
off to great start
[Music]
it is slam at the basket sits back gives
it up to a reason
s-six there he is
[Applause]
[Music]
in the 5757 Calvinistic
[Applause]
harm our 50 cent
[Music]